[Music]
science is not in the business of
shedding light on morold debates but I
think it can do sometimes the whole
subject of moral philosophy of examining
moral questions in a logical way to
expose inconsistencies for example when
you're looking at moral questions
so-called moral questions like abortion
or euthanasia you can show that people
who take a very strong absolutist line
may be being inconsistent with
themselves because they are taking a
strong line on one thing while at the
same time inconsistently not taking a
similarly strong line on another so that
will be a scientific way of thinking
it's not science per se its moral
philosophy but it's a kind of scientific
way of thinking but also I think
scientific facts can illuminate moral
debate in the case of abortion again for
example a science a scientist might
contribute to the debate information
about at what point during the
development of of an embryo the nervous
system comes into being and presumably
before the nervous system comes into
existence there is no ability to feel
pain or to suffer and so maybe something
important happens at the moment when the
nervous system comes into being on the
other hand you might say well even when
a human embryo develops a nervous system
and develops the capacitors it - perhaps
suffer it's still a much smaller nervous
system than the nervous system of an
adult cow and so what about balancing
the suffering of a human embryo against
the suffering of an adult cow when it's
being slaughtered for meat an absolutist
moralist would say well humans are just
plain special and cows are not human so
they don't deserve the same moral
consideration but a scientist might come
along and say well what do you mean by
that I mean we are after all all evolved
we're all cousins at what point would
you that want
point in the evolution of since we know
evolution is a fact at one point in the
evolution of humans would you suddenly
draw the line as they write from now on
they're all human and before that
they're not in the evolutionary
progression from the common ancestor
with chimpanzees lived about 6 or 7
million years ago to modern humans going
through creatures which might have
looked a bit like Lucy might have looked
a bit like the newly discovered fossil
ardi would you have given a special
human moral ethical consideration to
Lucy or would you count Lucy as though
she was a chimpanzee does this perhaps
suggest to you that we shouldn't be in
the business of drawing lines between
species in this kind of way maybe these
lines should be regarded as more fuzzy
and less clear-cut our absolutist
morality x' that do draw hard and fast
lines between humans and all other
species even taking a human fetus and
calling that human and aware as an adult
chimpanzee is not and doesn't deserve
the same moral consideration is that
consistent with with science these these
are ways in which science can at least
inform moral discussions
you can I suppose make a utilitarian
justification for obnoxious practices
you could make a utilitarian
justification for torture moral
philosophers sometimes pose the
hypothetical case where the world is
about to be blown up only one person
knows the secret password to stop the
Doomsday bomb going off only one person
doomsday bomb going off this one person
is a suicide bomber who refuses to give
up the password are you right to torture
him and most people I think say you are
I mean you're it's it's a horrible thing
to torture somebody but under those
extreme conditions to save the world you
wouldn't you would torture somebody so
and that would be a utilitarian
justification for an otherwise obnoxious
practice such as torture